pas un gilet jaune à l'horizon en ce
jour de semaine sur la zone commerciale
de châteaufarine côté commerçants et
sont peu nombreux à s'exprimer
affirmant avoir reçu des consignes de
leur direction parisienne
difficile dans ces conditions de savoir
si les actions des gilets jaunes ont
fait chuter leur chiffre d'affaires nous
on a été impacté en fait le premier
week-end quoi et puis aujourd'hui tout
se passe bien sur la zone de
châteaufarine c'est pas un blocage ont
fait ils filtrent quand même les
véhicules
c'est plutôt notre clientèle qui qui a
peur de sortir pour être bloquée de ça
se passe bien très bon il se dit même
qu'ici commerçants et gilet jaune se
seraient mis d'accord pour que ce samedi
cachet de noël se déroule sans
perturbation c'est une rumeur
on ne sait pas un accord l'information
n'est pas non plus confirmée du côté des
gilet jaune toujours mobilisés écoutez
moi je suis au courant de rien du tout
donc je suis vu que ya pas de leader on
sait pas trop n'est pas là pour pour se
mettre les commerçants à dos on comprend
qu'ils ont besoin de savoir pour
travailler c'est bien pour ça justement
qu'on préfère faire une manifestation
donc à pied en centre-ville en gênera
pas l'économie on sera juste à entendre
pacifiquement comme d'habitude ici les
gilet jaune seront donc pour la première
fois au centre ville de besançon ce
samedi les commerçants ont été informées
une réunion a eu lieu en préfecture
mardi soir et les boutiques seront
ouvertes
c'est une manifestation qui édite
pacifiste j'espère qu'elle le restera je
pense que les autorités ont mis en place
un dispositif de sécurité qui nous
permettra d'être d'être bien et de
pouvoir appréhender ce samedi sans aucun
souci un rassemblement est prévu à 13h30
au parking battant aucune information en
revanche concernant d'éventuels barrages
aux entrées des zones commerciales